the batman is a gritty three-hour
thriller that is sure to please dc
comics fans but what's the story behind
elratha aladda what's barry kyogen doing
in this movie your questions about the
ending answered straight ahead
the riddler takes aim at the inherently
corrupt institutions that hold gotham
together and he starts with mayor
mitchell the murder itself feels right
out of a slasher as the villain finds
his way into the mayor's office in the
dark stands behind him and waits for his
moment to strike it's immediately clear
that it's a huge step away from the
prancing trickster played by jim carrey
in batman forever this is director matt
reeves way of introducing us to the type
of threat batman is up against a villain
who isn't afraid to creep around in the
dead of night and commit heinous
atrocities in the name of vigilante
justice hang on that sounds an awful lot
like what bruce wayne does doesn't it
interesting anyway the first attack is
what sends a dark knight and james
gordon tumbling down a conspiratorial
rabbit hole regarding the mayor's
nighttime activities although they find
photographic evidence on a thumb drive
that he's been having an affair with a
young woman the riddler also sends the
images to the press so from the very
beginning the riddler's whole agenda is
to force the wrongdoers out into the
light he wants them to be humiliated for
their crimes and as the police scramble
to look for the riddler he strikes again
this time targeting commissioner pete
savage he sends a unique message by
killing savage with a horde of rats and
a bug strapped to the poor guy's face as
bruce soon figures out there's a rat at
the heart of gotham's corruption who has
caught the riddler's eye the riddler
calls this person alright
the rat with wings
as it turns out selena kyle's best
friend annika is a girl who's been
spending extra marital time with mayor
mitchell at the cd iceberg lounge and
her face is quickly plastered across
every tv screen in the city because of
batman and gordon's investigation
although selena tries to protect her it
isn't long before she disappears this is
what draws selena and batman together as
he promises to help her find out what
happened to her best friend the cat
burglar is only further inspired to get
to the truth when she discovers that
annika has been spending time in 44
below the mob's club within the club at
the iceberg lounge it quickly becomes
clear that annika has been kidnapped for
things mayor mitchell has told her about
the inner workings of his campaign and
who he really works for selena makes it
clear that she'll do anything to help
find her friend even if batman is too
preoccupied with the riddler but annika
is yet another victim of corruption as
the cat and the bat ultimately discover
her dead body while they're looking into
the penguin and his role in the mob it's
only hardened selena's resolve to get
revenge it's truly vigilante season in
gotham with catwoman batman and the
riddler all out enforcing their own
competing brands of justice
you really could be doing more for this
city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
sure bruce hasn't really spent much time
as a billionaire playboy philanthropist
but the world hasn't forgotten about the
waynes and what his parents did for the
city however the riddler forces the hero
to look closer at his legacy as he takes
aim at thomas wayne and his unsuccessful
mayoral campaign wayne senior started
the renewal project as part of his run
for mayor pouring millions into an
initiative intended to help the poorest
in gotham but the fame and attention
brought the paparazzi to his door
including a journalist working for the
previous mob boss salvatore moroney in a
surprising revelation we learned that
bruce's mother is a member of the arkham
family before her untimely death she
struggled with her own mental health
issues martha wayne was even committed
to a psychiatric facility something
thomas was desperate to keep out of the
papers his old friend carmine falcone
even had a journalist killed to keep
martha's secret the riddler uses this as
ammunition against the wayne family
suggesting that thomas was just as
corrupt as mayor mitchell and pete
savage it's a crushing blow for bruce
who holds his parents memory in such
high regard so batman has a crisis of
identity this information threatens to
invalidate his entire heroic crusade in
gotham bruce wayne would be hypocritical
for not addressing corruption in his own
family thankfully alfred convinces him
that thomas didn't care about his
mayoral campaign or preserving his
status he only wanted to keep martha
secret so that she wouldn't be
humiliated in the press yes thomas asked
foulconey for help but he didn't want to
assassinate the journalist not only does
this charge restore brewster's faith in
his mission it also forges a closer bond
between the hero and alfred
so who is elratha allada and why are
they so important well it all stems from
thomas wayne's renewal project after the
wayne's deaths the city's elite started
to use the millions intended to help
gotham's poorest to line their own
pockets the perpetrators of this
conversion included gangster salmaroni
but when the mayor and various other
powerful figures got greedy they decided
to get rid of him the problem is that
they used an anonymous informant elrata
aladda to do it surprisingly this
mystery snitch is none other than
carmine falcone carmine saw this as an
opportunity to extend his reach across
gotham to essentially have the mayor the
district attorney and the police
commissioner in his pocket unfortunately
selena kyle also figures out that
carmine is the one who ordered annika's
death and she almost kills him in
revenge it's understandable why selena
takes a shot at him because she's also
his illegitimate daughter her
assassination attempt is a culmination
of 20 years of pain knowing that he
abandoned her mother although batman
stops her from actually murdering
falcone the riddler finishes the grim
job with a rifle
thankfully because of riddler left
himself vulnerable by staying near the
crime scene it doesn't take long for the
gcpd to track him down and haul edward
nashton over to the arkham correctional
facility
yes it's time for the typical villain
explains their plan in great detail part
of the movie nashton's explanation
actually serves a key purpose this time
beyond lazy exposition he reveals a true
extent of the corruption that has
gripped gotham for decades and forces
the audience to face in an easy
comparison between himself and the caped
crusader you see ridler used to work for
the wayne's renewal project as a
forensic accountant and that's where he
discovered the dark truth while the
wealthy elite got richer by skimming
from renewal nashton was growing up in
one of the orphanages that should have
benefited from that money enduring a
horrific childhood in squalor he then
makes a disturbing confession he was
only spurred into action when he saw how
batman was tackling crime on gotham
streets yes bruce helped bring the
riddler to life he inspired the killer
to take the leap into vigilantism
meaning there's plenty of blood on those
bad hands of his to be fair the film
makes a point of showing just how brutal
batman is to the point that the
civilians aren't even sure if he's a
friend or foe it's hardly surprising
that other self-righteous foe could
follow in his footsteps unfortunately
there's little time for soul searching
here since riddler has already rigged
bombs around gotham seawall as a final
act in his war on the city
the final stage of the riddler's plan
sees the villain bomb the sea wall which
floods most of the city in a moment
comic readers will recognize from the
pages of the new 52's zero year event
the riddler's entire game has been about
forcing the corrupt into the light and
unearthing their crimes as well as
cleansing the city of its collective
sins by flooding the entire city he
plans to purge gotham of the ruts that
has taken hold while forcing the
citizens to start afresh although the
villain succeeds in flooding the city he
has another surprise up his sleeve as a
horde of his faithful followers are
waiting in the gotham arena which has
been set up as the emergency shelter for
survivors thankfully batman and catwoman
show up to dish out a beating this is
the first time batman truly feels like a
hero in the film rather than just a
brawler feeding his own thirst for
vengeance it's a critical moment that
draws a clear contrast between batman's
brand of vigilantism and riddlers after
all one vigilante is trying to
indiscriminately kill thousands of
people while the other is trying to
protect them even when he's at the point
of exhaustion on the floor batman uses a
suspicious green adrenaline shot to
force himself up so he can stop one of
the shooters from killing selena
ultimately this dynamic duo manages to
save the day as for that suspicious
green liquid we've gotta guess
it's the venom
yes riddler has been defeated but only
to a point it saves a lot that the
losing villains still manage to flood an
entire city while also single-handedly
proving that institutional corruption is
rife within the mayor's office and the
gcpd but since riddler is pretty
deranged here it's no surprise that he's
locked up in arkham and this is a comic
book movie after all so it's time for
that all-important sequel bait back in
2020 rumors swelled that director and
co-writer matt reeves was planning to
include the joker in his batman trilogy
and it seems this early speculation was
spot on while the riddler is crying in a
cell an eerie voice starts to creep in
from the cell next to his this menacing
neighbor has a scary smile as he tells
the riddler that everyone loves an
encore before saying you know what they
say one day you're on top of the world
and the next day you're a clown clown
joker you get it it's a brief scene but
eternal star barry kyogin really does a
lot with her it's unsurprising since he
already proved he can tackle difficult
characters thanks to his work in
american animals and the killing of a
sacred deer a joker riddler alliance
would be fun but it would be much more
interesting if gotham got caught between
the two we could be headed for a story
inspired by the war of jokes and riddles
so where does this all leave batman by
the time the action in gotham arena is
over he's immediately on disaster aid
duty he starts a film with a devil may
care attitude but he slowly realizes
that he can be a positive force for
changing gotham by trying to help its
people not just as muscle against
muggers and serial killers the prime
example of this is the way he leads some
of the survivors out of the wreckage it
absolutely hammers home the film's
central moral quandary what makes batman
good and riddler evil the answer appears
to be that for batman there's an honest
moral calculation between means and ends
it's clear to the hero that he can do
more when he helps a young girl who's
been evacuated she grabs his hand out of
fear and he's there to silently reassure
her that everything is going to be okay
despite his earlier claim
i'm vengeance
he's more than the retributive hand of
justice he also helps the people who
have been harmed riddler has no interest
in helping and for him the punishment
appears to be an end in and of itself
considering the film starts with batman
brutalizing a gang of thugs in the rain
this is all quite the optimistic and
hopeful development
he's not the only one who's changing
their outlook on life selena is also
ready to change her situation by the
time the credits roll
miss kyle decides to leave gotham for
bloodhaven a reference to the city
nightwing usually makes his home in the
hope that she can make a new life there
it's unsurprising that she needs a fresh
start after enduring so much trauma
thanks to her mobster father
unfortunately she can't persuade bruce
to join her because he's got a renewed
sense of faith when it comes to his
crusade to save gotham from itself but
she'll probably be back for the sequel
it'll be interesting to see whether
selena discovers his billionaire alter
ego in the future and whether that makes
him seem more or less eligible as a
romantic partner maybe we're not so
different
who are you under there
so the bat and cats say their goodbyes
in a race through gotham sprawling
necropolis by the angsty emo kids that
they are they even speed off in separate
directions with bruce heading back into
the city toward the light of the bat
signal check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one